قد نشعر يوما اننا لم نعد بحاجه لهذه
الاغراض ماذا نفعل فيها
فعل يعني او نقول تحرك او انه دائما احنا
نقول بانه هذه الاغراض عزيزه على النفس
ولكنها بس احنا على ما يبدو غلطانين وهلا
زميلتنا سمر راح تعطينا الخبر اليقين لانه
في بعض الاغراض اللي احنا بنعتقد بانه لا
قيمه لها وما الها يعني مش راح نقدر نرجع
نبيعها او نستفيد منها او نستثمرها باي
طريقه من الطرق الا انه على ما يبدو البعض
منها فعلا ممكن يكون مربح على كل حال
نبيعها ما نبيعها شو نسوي هل نهديها او
حتى كيف نبيعها
يعني اوكي بدي ابيع بس كيف
سمر الماشطه صباح الخير يعطيك العافيه
ممكن
المجوهرات ماشي ممكن اي شيء ذهب وكذا طبعا
البضاعه اللي هي عندك
الحقائب الفاخره الاحذيه الفاخره طبعا
اللوحات هاي كلها امور شوي تطلع قيمتها بس
عندك مثلا الاثاث الالكترونيات هاي لما
ترجعين تبيعيها تقل قيمتها اغراض البيبي
اغراض البيبي لها سوق جدا كبير لما ترجعين
تبيعيها الاغراض الكبيره مش بالضروره
الملابس نحكي على مثلا طاوله الغيار على
الاساس
مثلا انا بعد كم مره المونيتر حق اللي
يسمع صوت البيبي الكاميرا للامانه الاشياء
الالكترونيه هاي كلها تمكنت من هذه كيف
تفكرين بقيمتها كيف من الممكن ان تبيعينها
بالاضافه لان في بعض مثلا
الملابس البدل خلينا نتكلم بصوره عامه اذا
بدنا نتكلم عن اشياء تزيد قيمتها مثل
السلع الفاخره
مثلا التحفيات هاي الاشياء اللي تزيد
قيمتها ما حنتكلم عنها الان حنتكلم عن
بصوره عامه الاثاث والاشياء اللي قلنا
عنها هذه 50% تنزل سعرها اذا كان المنتج
بعدبي حاله جيده وما مستعمله هوايه عندك
مثلا 50% 50%
نقول سنه اذا عندك اذا كان مستعمل لبضع
سنوات اقل من خمس سنوات نازلين من قيمته
عفوا عفوا تصير قيمته 25% من الاصلي اذا
كان 75 يعني ايه تنزل 75 اذا اكثر من خمس
سنوات حتنزل قيمتها 90% يعني يا دوب
تبيعها لتخلص منه او حتى
تخلصها احسن بالضبط الملفت اليوم انه
الملابس مثلا المستعمله والاحذيه
المستعمله الها سوق كبير جدا اليوم
جينيريشن اللي هو الاصغر من بعد يعني اللي
قبلنا اشترى
سلع مستعمله وملابس واحذيه مستعمله بقيمه
177 مليار دولار العام الماضي
سوق كبير وهذا هذا الرقم سيصل الى 350
مليار دولار في عام 207 اول شي بسبب كان
عامل من العوامل هو التضخم ثاني شيء لانه
كان عندهم دخل متاح للانفاق قاموا ويصرفوه
على السلع الفاخره المستعمله ثالث شيء هذا
الجيل الجديد عده مبدا النويس او عدم
الهدر فلذلك هو يتقبل فكره الملابس
المستعمله انا ابني قبل فتره اعزل يعني
دولاب غراضه اشوف علب الاحذيه الموجوده
اللي مشتريها محتفظ فيها قلت لكم ليش خلي
لا اريد ارجع ابيعها لانه بدها تصغر علي
هو ديمو بسرعه فشوفي هذا الجرك كيف يفكر
على التيك توك وحط الاحذيه قلت لها شو
تفيد الاحذيه قال لي لا ممكن تزيد من قيمه
الشيء 5% لما يكون العلبه موجوده طبعا هيك
يمكن ابنك ممكن يدلنا
العديد من اليوم اذا عندك ملابس فاخره او
قطع فاخره او شيء مثلا حقائق فاخر احذيه
فاخره عندك مثلا عندك
العديد من الويب بس هاي تاخذ منك تقريبا
50% من
السعر طيب شو استفدنا اذا يعني اذا كانت
اصلا قيمه يعني اعاده البيع هالقد حسب لا
احنا لما نتكلم عن حقائب الفاخره حتكون
قيمه البيع عاليه بس لما نتكلم عن اشياء
بسيطه لا تحطيها
حطينا على هل تختلف يعني اليوم الكوب هذا
يختلف عن الملابس بايده كانوا استعمالهم
اقل من سنه هل انا انزل بالكوب هذا مثلا
ثلاثين بالمئه او 15% وبالملابس نسبه
معينه يختلف ما بين شيء واخر اكيد يختلف
ما بين شيء واخر يعني ممكن هذا الكوب همين
يكون مثلا
تبيعه انت بطريقه اليوم يقول لك دائما
انطي قصه فانت ممكن تطلع على
الانستجرام مثلا تبيع تقول هذا اول مق
اشرب فيه كوفي بالعربيه اول مره اخدت من
العربيه حطيت له ستوري ممكن زدت على قيمته
ممكن تختلف بس هو القاعده العامه مثل ما
قلنا بالبدايه انه 50% 25% 10% اذا كان
اكثر من خمس سنوات او حتى ببلاش
طيب وسمر لما تيجي انت تحطي اي من اغراضك
على وحده من هدول المواقع عشان تبيعيها او
على المحجبات انت اللي بتحددي السعر ولا
الناس بتصير تعمل زي مزاد لا طبعا ممكن
تسوين مزادات على السوشيال ميديا
تروحين مثلا عندك نفترض حقيبه شانيل
تريدين تبيعيها تروحين تدخلين اسمها
بالضبط وتشوفين المستعمله حتى واناناس
يبيع مستعمل فارش يبيع مستعمل يبيع عقلك
او ممكن انت تحطيه على السوشيال ميديا
تقارنين الاسعار اللي موجوده على باقي
المواقع تحطين سعر شويه يعني
يجذب اكثر من هاي المواقع ومثل ما قلنا
دائما مثلا حطي الصوره دائما استعملي ضوء
الشمس لما تصورين هذا النشره طبيعي الصوره
جماليه للمكونه او البضاعه اللي انت حابه
تبيعين لازم تحط مثلا السيريال نمبر
الاصلي بتحطي اذا في عيوب فيها مثل ما قل
دائما نحط انه مثلا انه القصه اللي وراء
هذه مثلا عندك اليوم خلينا نتكلم عن بعض
السلع اللي ارتفعت اسعارها الفاخره مثلا
عندك خلينا نتكلم سواء كارتير مستعمل سوار
كارتير مستعمل
6500 دولار هذا مقارنه ب 7600 الجديد يعني
مازال
ففي اشياء ممكن ترجعين تبيعيها وبربح
انتبهوا اغراضكم يا جماعه افرزوهم وبيعوهم
وخلي
البوكسز واستشيروا ابن سمر كمان
جزيلا لك يعطيك العافيه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات